hong kong international airport is a
quiet place these days
except here the check-in area for
flights to london
these people are not going away for
business or pleasure though
they're leaving for good feeling a
mixture of anger
guilt and a sense they're being forced
out this is our home
why do we need to leave i mean i have
been living here for more than 30 years
already and it's my home
so it's really sad to leave the home and
you see that everything is
deteriorating she's a finance worker
and has no job to go to like others
who've sacrificed careers
often for the sake of their children we
live here
for many years and we have
our career we have our families
so it's
a bit upset but for the
for the future of my children i think we
need to do it
these sad scenes are now being played
out daily
as more people join a growing exodus
from a territory
where communist party rule is being
tightened
in the past year an estimated 36 000
people
have left for britain under a special
visa scheme
many supported or were part of the
anti-government protest movement
like darcus hugh now in birmingham with
his family
he says the change to the immigration
law will encourage more people to go
i think the hong kong government speeds
up the immigration plan for many hong
kongers
for us we did not plan to leave hong
kong at the beginning even after the
protests in 2019.
like many others he says he's unlikely
to return to hong kong
a city that still regards itself as
asia's finest
the government denies the law gives it
unlimited powers
to stop people entering or leaving hong
kong
insisting the amendment is aimed at
screening illegal immigration at source
amid a backlog of asylum claims and that
people's right to free movement
will not be affected those who've gone
to the uk
have opted for a new life in a country
where covid 19 rates are soaring
and job prospects scarce yet that seems
preferable
to remaining here adrian brown al
jazeera
hong kong